I think that Joe Biden's problem is the
clear senility yeah was going with his
age I was on Piers Morgan a couple days
ago in New York City uh and we talked a
bit about Joe Biden's sort of crumbling
mental state and what that means for the
whole damn thing here's the thing I
think the problem it's not excuse me
it's not his age I think that Joe
Biden's problem is the clear senility
that's going with his age like I said I
met Jagger last summer absolutely
bursting with the vi and vigor that Jill
wants us to believe she sees in look
Piers do any of us sitting at this table
or anyone watching this think that he
could run one shift at McDonald's and I
don't mean that as a shot for someone
that works at McDonald's there
cognitively but but I don't think he
could I think a lot of senior citizens
could because I don't think it's an age
thing I agree with you it's it's a
cognitive D Collins at the emies stole
the show she's 90 years old good friend
of mine she looks about 50 and she has
the mental acuy of a 50-year-old she has
vim and vigor so I Jill Biden is right
to say it's about vim and vigor but her
husband doesn't exude it well look let's
put it this way you opened by saying
something about ailing Joe Biden and I
thought oh I haven't looked at my phone
in 20 minutes did something else happen
it's a general ailing it's ailing yes we
all know it the wandering off when they
put get him off the plane and the
confusion he literally on camera last
what was it 2 years ago said let's go
let's go Brandon like something is not
right we all know it and I would say
respectfully in terms of the polls and
everything people don't vote on what
really matters we vote on what we can
feel right and I think because of that
people are going Donald Trump he seems
back there's energy there and there's
just no energy with Biden nobody nobody
like of the clips of that guy I keep
telling you more more of that guy
whoever he is uh the point of all of
that is that if we all know that there
is something wrong with Joe Biden and at
the same time we have some sense perhaps
from New Hampshire that the crossover
people are not thrilled with Trump then
what we need to do if you do not want
Joe Biden or Camala Harris or Gavin
Newsome to be president we have to now
push on Trump a little bit to figure out
a way to get those moderates get those
it's it often is Suburban women who have
that major aversion to Trump and if
because if we don't do that we're going
to get the Democrats
again
I